xi jinping recibió respuesta a menos de
24 horas después de anunciar sus
intenciones de reunificación taiwán se
niega a ceder ante la presión china y le
ha apostado todo a la defensa nacional
no actuaremos apresuradamente pero no
debe haber ninguna ilusión de que el
pueblo taiwanés cederá ante la presión
continuaremos reforzando nuestra defensa
nacional y demostraremos nuestra
determinación de defendernos para
asegurar que nadie pueda forzar a taiwán
a seguir en el camino que china ha
dispuesto para nosotros la escalada
militar es la mayor de los últimos años
los sobrevuelos de aviones de beijing
sobre la isla de formosa fueron el
detonante pero la reivindicación de
china continental sobre taiwán es una
cuestión que viene de lejos formosa fue
el último refugio del derrotado de
ejército nacionalista durante la guerra
civil china y quedó fuera del poder del
partido comunista desde entonces se
autoproclama como un estado
independiente
de la reunificación completa a nuestro
país debe realizarse y puede realizarse
con la unificación es la esperanza de
todo el pueblo chino con inglés y ma
si china puede unificar todos los chinos
disfrutarán de una vida feliz si china
no pueda unificarse todos sufrirán
piensan
la cuestión taiwanesa amenaza la
estabilidad de la región mientras taiwán
es un firme aliado de japón y eeuu china
considera que es un asunto interno sobre
una provincia rebelde que debe resolver
[Aplausos]